let's say that you have a jar of jelly
beans and you know that there are
exactly
282 jelly beans in that jar of jelly
beans and then the next day you come and
you see there are fewer and you say what
happened and let's say someone who lives
with you or your friend says oh yeah i i
counted exactly and i ate 59 of those
jelly beans so you started with 282
59 are taken out
and you don't need to know exactly how
many jelly beans are left but you want
to estimate roughly how many jelly beans
are left and that's why as this title of
this video says we're going to
estimate when subtracting large numbers
and we can debate how large is large but
these aren't reasonably large so let's
do that let's see if we can estimate
what 282 minus 59 is and sometimes when
we're estimating we will use this
squiggly equal sign this means
approximately which is another just a
fancy way of saying roughly what is this
equal to
so the way that i would approach this i
would say hey are these close to numbers
that are easier to subtract with so for
example 282
i would say you know what maybe i can
round to the nearest 10 here and so i
could round it down to 280 if i round
down to the nearest 10 if i round it up
it would be go to 290 but 282 is closer
to 280 than it is to 290 so i would
round this
when i'm estimating to 280.
and then what about 59
if i were to round to the nearest 10
what would i round that to pause the
video and think about that
well 59 if i round down to the nearest
10 it would be 50 and if i round up to
the nearest 10 it would be 60 and 59 is
definitely closer to 60. so i would say
that this is roughly if i'm rounding i
could say hey i'm going to round that to
60. so i could say that 282 minus 59 is
roughly going to be 280
minus 60.
and now what is this you might be able
to do this in your head you could view
this as 28 tens minus 6 tens and so if
you have 28 of something minus 6 of it
you're going to be left with 22 of that
something and so you could say that this
is going to be 22 tens 22
tens or another way to think about it
you have two hundreds and then eight
tens and then you're going to take six
tens away from it so then you'll be left
with two hundreds and two tens just like
we have here so the whole point here
this is not this is actually not exactly
what 282 minus 59 is but if you just
said hey ballpark do i you know i want
to know if
do i have roughly how many jelly beans
do i have well this this could be useful
and you'll see later in life this is
actually a very very useful skill where
you might have these numbers they get a
lot larger than this but you'll round to
the nearest 10 or you'll round to other
places so that you can do that
computation in your head